hey everybody we are here because there
was a huge game this weekend the Super
Bowl just happened and we are movie
fanatic so yes we like football but we
also really like watching the trailers
and talking about the TV spots that were
on during the game and there were some
good ones in this game a lot of stuff
that we maybe hadn't seen already but it
was still nice to see during those spots
you wait you watch if you're a movie fan
like we are what are the big trailers
we're gonna talk about our favorite ones
we're gonna talk about the ones that may
be disappointed us all of them right
here JJ Abrams is no stranger to success
obviously when you see what he's done
with Star Wars and now with this movie
nobody knew this thing was coming out
well I think too we saw the first
trailer that came out and this one is
definitely a lot darker a bit scarier
and I think it's interesting when you're
watching the game to see where these
trailers ended up appearing and these
were that was one of the ones that was
pre game but let's talk about our
favorite yeah what is your favorite from
the game my favorite was x-men
apocalypse first couple images that came
out of Oscar Isaac as apocalypse people
are saying he looked like a Power Ranger
villain and I think it was and they
weren't in the first trailer of the show
they didn't focus on him yeah but in
this one you got clear shots of him and
he looks menacing when he's holding yeah
mystique up by the neck it seems like
this is going to be the x-men's biggest
challenge that was mine now what was
your favorite my favorite was the Jungle
Book
yeah I think that it was one of the only
ones where we did get to see a lot of
new footage where you did get to see
kind of the dark aspect of what we'd
already known about the jungle books but
then the end of it was so much fun and
light-hearted and reminded me so much
more of the animated film that I grew up
with and getting to hear you know
injuries Elba do the voice of Shere Khan
and seeing Mowgli so much more running
around the jungle and what his
interaction is with all the other
animals blew my mind and then on top of
that they had the like kind of where
they would come out of the letterbox so
it was like almost like 3d and you
didn't have a 3d TV it was certainly the
most creative for sure because it did
seem like you didn't even need the
glasses and the 3d images are popping
out of you but this was also the one I
thought that really had to hit it hard
because if you talk about whether it's
civil war even Jason Bourne people
really know those movies and not that
people don't know jungle both the
animation but a lot of people didn't
realize
live-action version was coming out and
the fact that all the animals would be
talking yeah the way that they did this
they showed some footage at d23 which is
disney's kind of if their own con or the
expo that they do and they showed
footage of them talking and everyone is
raving about it and then this other
trailer okay it looks cool and now
everyone else is on board cuz you got to
see balu talk oh yeah I see Sher Khan
yeah this was a trailer and the full two
minute rail is on online as well yeah
and so I think that that also kind of
just leads into this being a year of
talking animals does he look at a lot of
the TV spots that we had and you had the
Marmon with the talking beaver then you
had the Honda truck that was with the
Sheep then there was the puppymonkeybaby
so I think that people are seeing the
excitement of how cool it can be to have
talking animals there was oh there was
also the one with the two bears that
we're talking to each other bears always
talk every Civil War I feel it's true
did you have a favorite TV spot this is
a hard one because I guess for me it was
I know I love that I love that the game
is about football but then obviously
trailers and TV spots and there was one
that somehow found a way to meld the two
together Batman V Superman I mean that
was one of my favorites too but I think
that seeing that commercial that was for
Turkish Airlines and having it be that
perfect blending of a trailer and a
commercial it was really cool I thought
that there was a lot of comedy that
worked well this year for the TV spots
now let's jump into back to the trailers
yeah was there one that was
disappointing for you I think that I
mean I wanted more from Captain America
Civil War I don't I guess for me
watching it I didn't feel like I saw
anything that was like ah I totally knew
and I mean I think overall there wasn't
really a trailer that was like oh oh my
gosh for me this year and so that one
for me was one that I wanted to feel
that way and I think because I felt so
much that way with the last trailer that
we got from Civil War I would say
Independence Day for me too it looks
like that movie stuck in the night
it looks like all these other movies
have kind of evolved where it's a blend
of CGI yeah and good acting and
practical effects this one just looks
like CGI that doesn't look like a lead
character that has that that I don't
from that feeling like who is the lead
that's why I was going as far as like
Will Smith was the guy who brought all
of that yeah charisma and it was nice to
see
Goldblum back it was nice to see Bill
Pullman back but who's the lead yeah
Hemsworth well what would have been epic
is if they did have that trailer and
then it was like all the rumors about
will not being in it were untrue and he
was in the trailer that would have been
amazing okay that's our list that's
everything we liked those are the things
we were disappointed but no but I'm one
that was disappointing no rogue one
trailer man or any of the TV spots if
you want to see everything we just
talked about check out the playlist on
this channel and you can see it all and
make sure you guys let us know in the
comments below what were some of your
favorite trailers and TV spots and while
you're here click that little subscribe
button if you want more awesome movie
content with the two of us which you
totally do click